so we've talked about Benjamin Franklin
as a as a public leader we've talked
about him as a businessman we've talked
about him as an inventor and scientist
now I think the last piece of the
Benjamin Franklin puzzle is just him as
for like were him his founding father
yes and as a diplomat in particular
because he was America's first diplomat
the in about 1757 he becomes the
ambassador or agent of the Pennsylvania
Colony to represent Pennsylvania in
London with the ministers to try to make
sure that the rights of the assembly and
the people of Pennsylvania were taken
into account and eventually off and on
over the next you know 17 or 18 years he
becomes an agent for a lot of the
colonies and starts representing the
interests of the American colonies in
London this is a really important time
in American history because this is when
tensions between the u.s. between the
colonies and Great Britain are really
coming to a head you have the French and
Indian War really kind of part of a
larger European war but that ends in
1763 the the British want the colonies
to pay for it right that's the big deal
which is the British think that the
American colonies you know have to pay
because Britain helped protect them in
the French and Indian War and they just
start putting taxes on the American
colonies and the American colonies by
this point are as sophisticated and as
strong of an economy as Britain they
don't feel that they should be dictated
to by the people in London and they have
their own legislatures in each of the
colonies so they're saying yeah we know
we have to have taxes but our
legislators should do the taxes we don't
want taxation without representation as
became the rallying cry and so it was up
to Franklin to try to talk the British
Parliament out of things like the Stamp
Act where every time you bought a piece
of paper or a newspaper we had to pay a
tax to London and to give the power to
the colonial legislatures so he was
really you know when we read in the
history books this whole time
period of you know things coming the
tensions rising it was really Benjamin
Franklin that was trying to negotiate
communicate the anger really and he was
very close to a lot of the people in
London then it was part of the
Enlightenment as a wonderful picture of
him there in London in which says Isaac
Newton looking over his shoulder and so
he is part of that intellectual class of
like dr. Johnson and all the people in
London
but unfortunately the government is
still run by a very aristocratic Tory
elite and Franklin has trouble
convincing them to give rights to the
American colonies and this breaking up I
mean it does kind of paint him because
as you mentioned this is the
Enlightenment Benjamin Franklin is he a
key figure and he did bind electricity
he was a great scientist so this is this
great man living in a small house in
London right near the Parliament and
he's very well respected by all the
intellectuals but he gets treated very
badly by the Parliament at one point
he's called in front of what's called
the cockpit which is a part of
parliament and he is humiliated because
they make fun of him for trying to stop
the Parliament from taxing the colonies
and that enrages Benjamin Franklin and
that finally tips him over to being
closer to the side of we may have to
have a revolution and just break away
from England that actually leads to
family problems because his son yeah so
he brought his illegitimate son William
over with him and he's very close to
William but William becomes quite
aristocratic despite the fact or maybe
because of the fact that he was
illegitimate kid of a middle-class
person he starts hanging around with the
Dukes and the orals
and he ends up being appointed by the
crown basically the government in the
King to be the royal governor in New
Jersey so William Franklin becomes a
dedicated loyalist to the crown of
England just as his father Benjamin
Franklin is becoming a rebel and siding
with those who want a revolution and so
everything eventually and we know how
history went
1775 1776 hostilities begun 1775
Franklin goes back Franklin goes back he
goes back unsuccessful because he had
tried to stop the hostilities he gets
back to Philadelphia once again at
Market Street he comes off the boat and
everybody in Philadelphia is kind of
wondering is he loyal to the British
Empire in the crown or is he truly
joined the cause of revolution and he
has a meeting with his son who's in the
royal governor of New Jersey he tells
his son he's going to become a
revolutionary his son says I'm going to
stay loyal to the crown
they basically barely speak to each
other again for the rest of their lives
this is a great break and Franklin
announces to the people in Philadelphia
that he's going to join the cause of
American independence and that's when he
gets to work with Jefferson and Adams on
the declaration of independence in July
of 1776 and right after that in order to
make the declaration a reality they
realize we have to get France and on a
side of the war you mentioned that the
French and Indian War that the British
and the French had been fighting for a
century almost off and on so in order
for the u.s. to win its independence in
a war against Britain it would help to
have the support of the French who were
naturally willing to fight Britain given
any opportunity and were already part of
a larger global war with Britain so he
becomes ambassador in Paris in order to
get the French and now if you look at
those two pictures that's kind of cool
because there's Franklin in London you
know looking like quite a gentleman in a
velvet coat when he gets to France he
realizes that the French people have
been reading young Jean Jacques Rousseau
maybe once too often about all the
natural man and the forest and how the
natural philosopher comes from the
backwoods Franklin never lived in the
backwoods he lived in Boston in
Philadelphia in London his whole life
but when he gets to Paris he wears a
Coonskin cap and sort of a backwoodsmen
coat so that he can appear to the French
as sort of this wilderness natural man
philosopher from the
aras talking about independence and
liberty and that's what he mean you know
essentially most of the rest he does
eventually return but he's in Paris he
does convince the French to get in on a
side to get on the side of the war and I
mean he spends a significant amount of
time there and become it becomes a grand
old man in Paris first of all as a
diplomat convincing the French to come
in on our side of the war as a publicist
eprint he makes a printing press in his
house near Paris
place called Posse and he prints the
Declaration of Independence and all the
great documents coming out of America of
course he's renowned as a scientist
because the French had been the first
people to do his lightning rod
experiments so they loved him in France
and he's kind of he has you know debe
readers died by this point so even as
he's in his 70s he has two famous
girlfriends mistresses in Paris and he
writes wonderful poetry and baguette
tells and stories to them so he is a
great bon vivant in Paris it's a bit of
a Parisian very much of a Parisian and
drinks wonderful amounts of Port John
Adams also has to come to Paris at a
certain point john adams is very much
the Puritan and even though they had
worked together for many years they
didn't really like each other and john
adams was appalled at franklin having
two girlfriends and getting up late in
the morning and drinking a lot of port
and brandy but it is Franklin who's able
to get the French in on our side and
then the triumph in Paris is called the
Treaty of Paris when the war is winding
down and blue and Benjamin Franklin is
able to negotiate the treaty with
Britain to end the American Revolution
and give the u.s. its independence and
it ends the war and Franklin was able to
do it working with the French sometimes
behind the back of the French a very
wily diplomat and at that point they've
kicked John Adams out because I know in
like Ben Franklin's a guy who can make
this complicated piece happen and
electable oh yeah yeah it was definitely
if you had to choose who you're going to
spend the evening with in Paris you'd
pick Ben Franklin over John
even though we have to give John Adams
our select from being a very very
important patriot and just big picture
this was once something that was
surprising to me is that Benjamin
Franklin who is you know kind of one of
our larger-than-life founding fathers
his role was not to pick up a musket his
role was you know for the kind of second
half of his life he was in Europe he was
in London he was in Paris and he was
really there to represent the country
and to negotiate with both England as
kind of an adversary or eventually an
adversary and and with Paris as an ally
and we would not really have won the
revolution without his diplomacy because
it's a French who send most of the
Gunpowder we use most of the troops use
its version the French foreign minister
who helps send a navy so that at
Yorktown when George Washington wins the
battle that pretty much ends a
revolution because the French Navy is
there supporting him so all of these
things work and finally near the end you
know in 1885 I think as he's you know
just about to turn 80 he comes back for
the last few years of his life gets
involved in the Constitutional
Convention and becomes a great elder
statesman fascinating